so over the weekend we've got some big
spider-man news an official title and
new pictures also let's just get this
out of the way first
I suppose it's set image from The Dark
Knight Rises crazy people live there
that would be I can just like picture of
Batman walking by a cell and like in the
darkness you see some guy needs like why
so serious the new spider-man film will
have people know that I'm a little upset
about the fact that that's being made
however I just want to clarify one thing
I really hope it's good I'm totally
excited for a good spider-man movie
I don't think of reboots a good idea
that's basically my stance the
spider-man reboot is officially called
the amazing spider-man which i think is
a really good title because that's what
the comic book is called the original
comic book in fact the original working
title of Sam Raimi's first film was the
amazing spider-man so that's kind of
made - so here's our second official
look at the new spider-man this time is
the mask on no I'll admit that I like
this picture a lot more than the first
one and that's because of one reason all
of the parts of the suit that I don't
like are blocked I'm not a big fan on
the gloves but I can deal with them ok
they're they're little weird but
whatever all the stuff I don't like the
back and his lower half are all blocked
like the boots I don't like how there
isn't a red belt here I don't like how
on the back it like has like this
upwards indentation thing going on and
one of the biggest things I've gotten
from people is that yes it does not look
as good as the original suit but that
makes sense because a teenager who is
admittedly very poor and still in high
school would not be able to afford to
make such a good suit like in the first
film and I was thinking hmm that's kind
of true but in this new high-res photo
I'm sorry there's no way a teenager is
gonna be able to afford to make that
suit either it's very high quality and
you know what that's fine with me I
don't want to watch a full spider-man
movie with a spider-man you know
spinning around and like some fabric
store clothes thing that he sewed
together in his room I mean it would
look it would just be stupid I'm fine
with an expensive looking suit that
doesn't bother me however what is with
this photo it looks like Spiderman got
scared and peed his pants I don't
understand what's going on there
basically I just don't like how they're
making it look all hip and snazzy and
stuff they are including the
web-shooters from the comics which a lot
of fans are happy
about however I really kind of agree
with Sam Raimi's stance he allowed
spider-man to spin his own webs he got
all the powers of a spider yes spider
sense spider agility climb walls white
candy spin webs it makes sense but this
is staying a little more true to the
comics which I can't fault it for all in
all I really hope this is a good film I
just I'm not a fan of the costume and
obviously I've seen enough of it now to
know that I'm probably never going to be
but that is the big news from Hollywood
I have for you today I'll be back this
weekend with a review for unknown
starring Liam Neeson